ですから それと関係なくもう幸福でありますようにと
そういう思考も働かせちゃうと
どんどんどんどん思考パターンが定着しちゃうんですね
思考パターンが定着したら
まあ人生はかなり善多く罪罪少なく人生になるんです
完全に罪から消える もう人は悟らなきゃできませんからね
ですから この仏教文化っていうのは
そういうもう並の文化じゃないんです
キリスト教文化とは随分ものすごい違う
すごいきちんともうできているんですね
ですから 仏教文化っていうのは崩壊するのはそれほど簡単にできません
まあ崩壊したければ 欲を欲と怒りを消滅するしかない
なぜか 小さい時からの生命は平等であって
誰にも微かな 被害 なんて言いますか
害を与えてはいけないと
与えたら返ってくるんだと
あんたという風な教え方だから
ですから ゴキブリでもアリでも
本当に自分と同じ生きてるものやってですから
もうアリもいじめてはいけませんという人々に
そういうふうに育てた人々に
偉大なる慈悲の神様が人間を作ったんだと
それで人間のためにこんな美しさが作ってくれたと言ったら
もうバカバカらしくて聞いていられないんです
それこそものすごい悪で聞こえるんですね
とんでもない悪の教えだ
なぜならば 人間と動物は丁寧に区別してるんだから
人間には魂を吹き込んだと
動物は単なるもう物扱いされているんだから
ですから このなかなかもう人気ないというか
ね 帰らないんですね 文化という
そういう仏教的な そういうきちんとした文化
強烈に据えてない場合は
すごいかっこいい かっこいいと帰りますけどね
ヨーロッパ文化って まあ小さい時からの
やっぱりこの仏教の世界っていうのは
まあ教育環境は大変気にするし
自分小さい時からの正しい価値判断は入れてある
それは難しいことじゃない
言ってること正しいんだから
子供はすごいわがままでしょうに
それで日本でわがままを正当化するんだけど
僕らの場合は絶対正当化しない
で 例えば私は小さい時
面白くて小さな鳥を捕まったならば
あんた好きだから勝手もいいよと絶対言われなかったんです
何回も鳥を捕まろうと弟といろいろ計画企んだんだけど
大変なことで終わっちゃったんですね
結果 で 隠れてなんかちょっと罠を仕掛けて鳥を捕まえようと弟といて
もうなかなか捕まらなかったし
バレちゃったんですね
母 バレたらもういきなり原爆でも落ちたか
何をするんですかと もしあなた方がその鳥を捕まったとすると
その鳥にも母親がいるんだと
父親がいるんだと 家族がいるんだと
あなたは捕まって檻に入れて
それでいいと思いますかと
そこでわからない それで私たちは
それでも鳥が可愛いという感じだから
急に言ったら じゃあ恐ろしい人が来て
お前を捕まってどこかへ連れて行って
檻に入れて鍵をかけて
誰にも会わないようにしたら楽しいですかと
私たちにも会わないんだと
なんか夜怖くなっちゃったら
私のところにそろそろ来られないんだと
それでどう思いますか？といったら
いきなりこの母の愛情と母から離れたらどんな自分が恐怖感生まれるだろうと
すぐ頭にくるでしょうね
それでなんか実感が生まれたんですね
この鳥の立場から鳥を捕まったら
あの鳥がどれほど泣くだろうと
どれほど寂しくなるだろうと
お母さんのところに行けなくなって
という風に この子供なりに
この自分と同じ生命見られるようになっちゃう
それからは動物と遊んだんだけど
やっぱり自分と同じという感じで遊んだんですね
アリを捕まる時でも もう怪我しないようにと
ちょっと捕まっても体の上をいろいろ動くこと
それはいろんなことを見たりとかね
行く道を間違わせたりとかね
でもあまり害をしない
小さな虫なんかでも もう捕まって強引ではなくて
私がやったことは虫を捕まえたいんで
あれはだいたい手なんか入れておくんです
入れたら向こうは間違って枝だと思って手にボロンと
そこで取ったそう そういう風な感じでも頭をそこまで
まあどうせガキだからね
まあいろいろ虫捕りたいし
見たいし 観察したいという興味
好奇心もあります で 相手には何の害も与えないで
まあそういうふうにやるようにできたんですね
ですから その価値観っていうのは小さい時からも簡単に入れられます
それまた事実だから 後でその人は精神的に大変なことになったっていうことは全然ありえないんですね
いくら大きくなったっていうのは
その事実はそのまんまでしょうに
あの舌が抜か 閻魔さんに抜かれるんだから嘘を言うなって
そんなこと言わないんです
お化けが出るんだからこうこうやるなとかね
それ嘘の教育じゃなくて
事実をちゃんと臨場があって
感情があって教える教育システムっていうのは
仏教文化にはちゃんとあるんです
閻魔さんなんかは要りません
そういう風にこの人間の
ですから私はすごいいろんな混乱やらね
いろんなぶつかり合ったんだから
こう日本で慈悲の瞑想をしようと思ったら一人も理解しない
それまたもう攻撃までする
わしと理解 何者かと これはあんた方人間でしょという感じなんですね
なんで当たり前のことを理解しないかと
生命愛することは これはもう論理も理屈も何もない
もう当たり前のことでしょうと
それができないって これものすごく不思議で不思議で
もう理解できなくて それからまた自分の学問的な知識使わなくちゃいけない
じん なんていますか sociology
それでまあいろんな sociology というくだらない学問を勉強したんだからね
ああ なるほど いろいろ society がありまして
そのその society の価値観はまたまたそれぞれ違うと
そのその society にはそれなりのくだらない宗教あるんだと
日本人は全部神様に作られたと思ってるし
その神って大したことない
本当にくだらないんだけども
それでもこちらの文化だと
他の国行ったらまた他の物語ですか
そういうインチキ物語で文化できてるんですね
あ それで価値観決めてるんだと
あそこはそれを丁寧に教えなくちゃいけないんだと
ですから この人間の由来やらね
例えば日本語はどのように現れたんですか？とか言うと
この私も読んでみたんだけど
あきれちゃうんですね
この伝統的な このもう history 読むと
それほどもう history にならないほどおかしいと言えばね
ですから そういう価値観でね
だから山は神になって
そのままやっちゃうし
なんとかしてなんとか山になった
ああだこうだとかね あんまり教育にならないんです
そういうの ですから この仏教は初めから輪廻の概念からね
まあ人間というのは もう生命はみんなそういう風にもう宇宙は変化していくわ
地球は変化していくわ
もう時代時代に人間はね
現れて消えて現れて消えたりするわとかね
私に教えてくれた history っていうのは
例えば昔あの母親にも教えてもらったんだけど
この今はこういうお釈迦様の教えがあって
仏教があって こういう風にあるんだけど
人間どんどん仏教は嫌いになるんだと
どんどん人間は修行しないようになるんだと
もう日常で食べて遊んで
そういう人のものを盗んででも食べて
遊ぶように社会が変化するんだ
そういう悪いことをすると
お互いに殺し合いやったり
盗み合いやったりするようになるんだと
そうすると どんどんみんなお互いに喧嘩したり
平和がなくなると どんどん人間というのはさらにさらに悪くなっちゃうんだと
さらに悪くなっちゃうと
寿命も短くなって お互いにみんな消えていっちゃう
それで一人も仏教の話を知らなくなっちゃうんだ
また地球も滅びて またいつかまた生命が生まれてくるんだ
それで遠い未来 人間またお互いに愛するようになって
道徳を守るようになって成長してくると
この遠い未来 現れる弥勒菩薩が現れるんだというふうにストーリーだから
すごいもう長い時間経過のもうストーリーであって
それは嘘やあだこだと思ったってもいいんだけど
やっぱり科学的な知識やいろんなものを積み込んでみても否定はできないことだから
神様が川になったと言っちゃったら
それちょっとわからなくなっちゃいますけどね
そういうことで この教育のことなんですけど
やっぱりしっかりと小さい時からのこの価値観
思考方向性決めさせておかない人間にはもうかわいそうですね
人間で生まれたことを
この異界の道を見ると
我々の理解できるのはそういうことで
心に何かアイディアが生まれちゃったら
その瞬間で即興心 7つ生まれて
カルマは完成して 感情は完全に生まれて終わっちゃうんです
ですから 体でやることよりは
頭の中で回転する我々の妄想に徹底的に注意した方がいいんです
だから 本当に恐ろしい毒が心の中に回っているんです
本当の猛毒が心の妄想なんです
それは僕は大げさに言っているわけじゃないんです
じゃあ精神的な病気の人々を見てください
全て妄想から生まれるでしょうね
あるいは何か食べ物が合わなかったんだからといって薄毛になった人がいるんですか？誰かが
世の中であるレストランに行って
誕生日でご飯食べようといったところで
食べ物がちょっと合わなかったんだと
ちょっと食べ物当たって下痢になったと
それからその人薄毛だと
あるわけないでしょうに
そんなことは 対人関係できないんだと
それはホウレンソウ食べてるんだからという
ありますかね そんなことは
だから一切の精神病っていうのは妄想から生まれるでしょうに
体の病気ってお医者さんに行っちゃえばすぐ治してくれるでしょうし
下痢になっちゃったら一発でそれ止まってくれるでしょうに
下痢になって体の水分も全部出ちゃったんだと
それで意識がもうろうになったら何のことないんです
お医者さんに行っちゃえばもう 15 分で治しちゃうんですね
でも精神病はどうですかね
人に会いたくないんだと
それ治せますかね そういうのは全部心で余計なことを考えるんだからなんですね
ある人が小さいとき 父親がすごい厳しかったと
それで父親が嫌いになって
いまだに会社でうまく仕事をできないんだと
冗談じゃないでしょうに
そんな話は それでいろんなことをやっても
なかなかいまだにもう対人関係もうまくいかないんだと
自信がないんだ あんなこと正真正銘の嘘でしょうに
父親が厳しいんだからといって人が病気になるわけないでしょうに
父親だから厳しくなるのは当たり前であって
母親は優しくいろいろ庇ってくれる
父親がピシピシと言っちゃうしって
そういう風にちゃんと仕事を分担して子供を育てるのは世の中の常識でしょうに
私の場合も父親は徹底的に厳しかったし
別に全然父親を恨んだことは一度もないんですね
覚えてるんです 一回 二回ぐらいすごく可愛がってもらったことがあったんですね
たった一回 二回とか それすごくありがたくてありがたくてと覚えてるんですね
それでもうるさいとかね
何やってるんですかと叱るだけ
でもそれで精神的に病気になったとか
そんなことないんですね
大人になってくるとよくわかるし
父はそういう態度をするかと
それで大きくなってわかったのは
父親っていうのは愛情表現っていうのは下手ということはよくわかったんですね
で 私の妹がいて 妹は何かきちっと何か怒ってどっか出て行っちゃったんですね
ずっと二人が一緒にいたんですね
ずっと一緒にいたんだけど
ほとんど喋れないんですね
もうなんか妹がなんかすごく病気になっちゃって
なんか父に言ったみたいですね
どうせ女の人だから まあどうですかって
ちょっと聞いて欲しかったかもしれませんけど
大人だからね 父親はあまり気にしなかった
それで怒ってどっか出て行ったと
僕はものすごい遠いところに行ったんだけど
もうかなり離れたところ
私のところに連絡が入った
私も一度もなかったことだからね
妹が家出しまったっていうこと
でもまあ それ妹はすごくできた人でも
別におばちゃんの家に行っただけなんですけど
で 聞いたら私も驚いちゃって
うちに帰ったんです 帰って
そこで初めてわかったのは
父親っていうのは本当に下手だなと
僕は行っても座ってる椅子から動こうともしない
喋ろうともしない なんか完全麻痺した状態で
どういうことかと聞いても何か言ってるんですけど
言葉が出ないんですね
そこで僕に見えるのは
どれほどその自分の娘のことをどれほど愛情があるということと
それでもうショックの状態で体も動かない
何もできない 喋れない
黙っている でも人間にとっては
あなたのことを大変心配しているという表現ぐらい必要であるし
僕はうちに行く前に全部ちゃんとチェックして
どこにいるかというのがわかって
そのまま車で何も言えないと
じゃあ車に乗ってくださいと
で ずっとまたすごい遠いところなんですけど
ものすごい田舎で 行って
この母の姉でしたから
やっぱり寂しくなっちゃうとそこに行って甘えてもらうんだからね
もうしょうがないし そこへ行ったら
もう何のことなくニコニコとみんなとふざけて遊んで妹がいるんですよ
これは僕はなんであんたお父さんに言わないで来たの？もうすごく頭が痛くて痛くてね
でもどうしようもなくても行ったんだけど
全然無関心でした だから私はこっち来たんだ
まあそれだけのことが
で そこでまあそこを僕はまあじゃあまあ帰りましょうって言ったら
もう妹も車に乗って車に乗ったとたん
お父さん あれはもう何もなし
昔話やら人の話やら しゃべればしゃべればうるさくて
うるさくて なんとか人はなんとかそういうこと
そこでまあわかるでしょうね
機嫌が戻ったと あまりにも楽しくて
だから聞いたこともない
お前戻ってよかったとかね
おかえりなさいとかそういうのはなし
その代わりにまあ昔話やらああだこうだとか
だから愛情っていうのはそんなもんで
表現できる人がいて できない人がいて
そこはまあ人間妄想しちゃうと変なもんじゃないんだよ
客観的にものを見れば何のこともないし
ですから 父親は厳しかったんだからと
いまだに社会に溶けないんだというのは
その本人が悪いだけであるし
本人の考え方がおかしいだけであって
妄想ばっかりしているんだから
父親に嫌われてるんだとか
勝手に思うでしょうに
それじゃなくて直接聞けばいいでしょうに
あんたは私のこと嫌いですかと
それはその自信がないし
例えば まあお父さん 私のこと嫌いだから私は家出しますよと
家出したって お父さんは何を言うんですか
はっきり言うよ お前のこと嫌いわけじゃないでしょうと言いながら怒るかもしれませんだけど
ですから それぐらいもしないで
頭の中で妄想して妄想して精神的に病気になる
妄想するたびに それは完全なカルマになる
ですから カルマの 7 分の 1 が今世で受けるでしょうに
だから今世で全部悪いカルマを受ける
かわいそうなんです 私も悪いカルマいっぱいしてるんだけど
ずるいんだから今世で入らないように気をつけてるんです
こういう人々が だから今世で 7 分の 1 は確実に今世でもらって
来世でも残り 7 分の 1 をもらって
輪廻の中で残る 7 分の 6 をまた不幸になるんだから
冗談じゃないんです だから悪い妄想が生まれたら完全にカルマなんですけど
その結果 今世に入る場合は精神的な病気なんですね
ですから このあの軽々く見るものじゃないんです
我々の妄想 意識の回転というのは徹底的に気をつけなきゃいけないんです
お釈迦様おっしゃるのは
人が心さえ守れば何も要りませんと
あるお坊さんがなんかお釈迦様に文句言ったんですね
戒律がありすぎて覚えられなくて
もう嫌ですよ 私は 1つも守りたくない
面倒くさいと 言ったら
お釈迦様は普通すごい厳しいなのに
なんのことなくその人の性格がわかるんだから
まあ七面倒くさがり屋だから
もう戒律というのはすごいきめ細かく分析
きめ細かく分析してるし
なんのことのかわかりましたと
じゃあ一つだけ守れますかと
一つだったらもう守りますと
約束します もうお釈迦様がおっしゃるならば
もう徹底的に一つだけでしょう
はい そうです 守りますと
じゃああなたは戒律は要らない
なくてもいい 心だけ守ってください
で よしわかったと 心守りますと
それでその人はもう完璧に悟りましたから
だからいくら七面倒くさがったんだけど
例えば食事をちゃんと手に渡さなくちゃ食べてはいけませんとかね
それでややこしい それだけなんまあ最近読んであるお坊さんの本なんですけども
こちらの方々の間でも知ってるお坊さんですけど
いくらかはしっかりしたことを言うんだけど
戒律の部分囲いしたらもう腹立ったんですね
道場に入って食べ物 スープとか食べる時は気をつけて
この熱いものを食べると
この口で吹く時はフーフーとすごく気をつけなさいと
もしあの唾液ですか わずかでもそれに入ったら
あなたはそれを食べてはいけませんよと言うんですね
ちゃんと受けたものは食べなきゃダメですよ
戒律では あの人バカではないかと思ったんだけどね
そんな戒律はあるわけじゃないし
戒律はもう 大変 もうその国で頭の良いお坊さんが言うんですけども
まあ私にそれ言っちゃったらとことんやっつけるんだけどね
で 知識のなさすぎかというか
まあ余計な混乱させるとことというかね
自分の体の唾液が外に出たら
それまた異物であって
人のものであって 人から受け取らない
それでもうパチッてやって
こういう罪を起こしたことになるんだとか書いてあったんですね
この坊主もどこの坊主じゃないか
本当にもうわかってないんだ
ですから そこまでくだらないことをね
なくてもいいし ですから
問題は心にあるんだから
心だけきちんと守れば全て守ったことになるんです
それでそれは心の流れがそういう風に流れるということを覚えておいてください
で この一つのセットがほんの瞬間で起きちゃうんです
ほんのわずかな瞬間 我々の知識というのは
そういうセットはもう何回も何億回も繰り返してから
やっとバラの花だとわかるんです
花を見て これバラの花だと判断する瞬間では
心っていうのはもう億単位で流れてるんです
で 以上です ありがとうございます